hey there reject nation
Greg Alva here John here did you catch
our midnight reaction to transformers
bumblebee movie I hope you did we got up
a little late and now we're here to
watch the lego movie two trailers all
the week of trailers before going into
this one I just want to say I fit into
this shirt finally the other thing I
want to say is patron of the day shout
out for Adelia Chamberland Delia your
birthday was recently you just turned 21
you don't look a day over 12 I am so
happy you are aging gracefully
it can be tough when women have
birthdays I know because they stress out
about getting older or some hormonal
thing but you are handling it well yeah
way way to confront mortality with poise
and grace and I know it can be boring
where you live pick up a Lego set and
build something great that's always a
good it's always a good idea and you
know make little lovers out of it too
let's watch the lego movie two trailers
I really don't remember loving it a
lifetime has passed since the horrific
Avenged
Our Lives descended into chaos two
copies please
one black one with just a touch of cream
in 25 sugars Wow toughened last about I
wake up in the morning babies Emmett
you've gotta stop pretending everything
is awesome
it isn't yeah I get it and that's why
I've cultivated a totally hard-edged
side that's super tough and
[Music]
what is it up to that beat is pretty
fresh chili innovation
[Music]
[Music]
it's like it knows our every move weird
right yeah well technically I did the
warrior stuff so you fought and
masterbuilt and hit but and then the
hapless male was the leader he well
[Music]
hang on to your fronds safer we're going
to save Lucy and all of the other people
who were captured
[Music]
behold the sISTAR sister not give her
the satisfaction of wooing miss
[Music]
nice hey star-lord and Captain Marvel
are in this movie yeah I remember my
experience and my emotions more of
watching the lego movie more than I do
the actual film I remember loving it and
being wowed amazed by it was like one of
my favorite movies that year looking at
this trailer it looks cool I mean the
animation still looks great but there's
something about it where I don't kind of
feel like this look all that special yet
yeah I kind of them there with you I
feel it's really a lot of fun beats and
it has a lot of that same energy like it
looks like it's picking up you know
going off where we left off with the
last lego movies there are things that
make me hopeful for it but yeah there's
nothing in this trailer that wowed me or
grabbed me particularly and I don't know
if that's just the influx of light you
know having Lego Batman lego ninjago and
then we have this I like that they
didn't really have a lot of Lego Batman
in here I mean Will Arnett's credited as
third billing so I imagine it'll still
be a good amount of Lego Batman in this
movie you know that was going back to
Chris Pratt's Emmet for most of it and I
also like that I think the last one ends
on the tees of an alien invasion and now
it's picking up in this like fury road
you know characters have just destroyed
bricksburg it was like fury road
references right that's what I look
completely identical to it fury road and
then just you know any apocalypse which
I'm sure the young kids all watched Mad
Max this looks like the light fall it's
just I remember the first one being like
incredibly clever however I'm also
remembering that when I saw the trailers
for the first lego movie I remember
thinking like this looks fun this is
pretty much the same feeling enjoyable
but it doesn't look like all that
amazing but I wasn't prepared for this
to kind of blow my mind yeah anyone was
and that's kind of the same exact
feeling I'm getting right now well the
other thing I walked into this trailer
with was just the idea that like I think
we both kind of have that thing we're
like I liked Lego Batman but I didn't
love Lego Batman and then I heard
Ninjago this formulas kind of getting
stale basically so now I'm wondering for
this if they're gonna change anything
up or if they're gonna keep that same
kinetic style I mean like its references
to Chris Pratt and like not everything
is awesome
like yay remind us about that song
thanks even though we already saw it on
the phone everything is awesome
I don't know that joke were the blinker
I've heard I've seen that done to death
so many times how are they following us
you're using your signals like I've seen
that joke done so many that's like a TV
show joke I am a little skeptical
because this is not the Lord and Chris
Miller who directed this there were one
of several writers on this there are two
of 4ko writers although one of the
others is Raphael bob-waksberg who's the
showrunner for Bojack horseman which is
a well-written show I feel like I have
faith in the writing staff the guy who
worked on this he directed a couple of
movies I like sky high I really enjoy
trolls Bigelow he's also directed Sponge
Bob sponge at of water surviving
Christmas shrek forever after Alvin and
the Chipmunks - chipwrecked he's done
movies that I I'm not particularly fond
of there's something about this that
seems like it's missing some type of
cleverness and then again I am
questioning myself because I'm thinking
like I might be judging it too harshly
because it's just the first trailer for
this movie with the great hype and
everyone wanting a lego movie - for so
long you're probably expecting something
to be a little bit more mind-blowing on
its first appearance yeah for sure I
mean you want something that's gonna
promise you something just as good if
not better than the first one in this
yeah just mostly looks like a fun
animated movie this is kind of how it
went down with the first lego movie we
were all a little skeptical and then it
came out and blew our minds and I hope
they can do that again yeah well guys
I'm so enjoy watching the trailer of
kelabra here you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification Belka subscribe buttons are
broken and now you can check us out on
patreon we do full-length TV show
reactions to many TV shows weekly Q&A is
music video coverage would love to have
you become a patron object to dad